is rt international on this friday
thanks for joining us so far moscow has
now registered its highest
ever daily covert infection rate with
more than 9 000 people catching the
virus in the last 24 hours
the city's mayor says a host of new
restrictions are being brought in for
example
you now have to be vaccinated to receive
non-essential
hospital treatment let's learn more on
this now artists ilya patrika joining us
live on the program ilya
it's a beautiful sunny day here at
moscow and now all we're hearing about
are restrictions due to a surge in
covered numbers what restrictions and
what is happening in moscow right now
rory hey there indeed a beautiful day
but
unfortunately bad news when it comes to
covet
now just to put this into perspective i
can tell you that
on june 9th uh there were a bit
under 3 000 new cases
for covet that was less than two weeks
ago but
now we have more than 9 000 new cases
in a single day and uh that is
impressive
this is more uh in fact two times worse
than
uh the uh daily rise in such country as
mexico for example
so this explains why new measures are
being announced and
we have a number of updates from
moscow's mayor sergey sabiani and for
instance he's saying that
almost 90 percent of the new covet
uh infections in moscow are uh the delta
variant that originated in india
and uh besides the sergey sabanian is
saying that uh
the uh so-called collective immunity is
supposed to be
two times stronger in order to
battle this delta variant uh now when it
comes to the measures
uh i can tell you that uh perhaps the
ones
that i it is fair to say that even
shocks and moscowites
uh came uh from the city's
medical authorities they're saying that
free non-essential care
at the hospitals in the russian capital
will only be provided
to those who have been vaccinated but
then of course if you need urgent
treatment
or if you're a cancer patient or a
patient
with blood diseases surely you will get
that uh
medical treatment now uh when it comes
to
uh the measures that will be felt
throughout the city
uh i can tell you that mass gatherings
of more than 1 000
people have been banned dance floors
and football fan zones have been closed
and the other restrictions that were put
in place just a few days ago
they will remain in the russian capital
at least
until the end of june now sergey
sabianin
maintains that the only way to battle
this pandemic
to finally win this war on kobit
is mass vaccination and he also said
that booster jabs are already required
in the russian capital and the city
authorities are currently working on
starting this campaign
it's vitally important to roll out
booster jabs now
that's why we will work with the
government to enable them to reach a
decision on the timing and technology
fast
the first component of the vaccine will
be used for the booster shot
if you had both sputnik v components you
should get another
first component this is currently the
only option
now besides this moscow is also set to
become
the pioneer in a different initiative
that's going to become
an experiment so-called covet free
restaurants
in bars in approximately 20 location
this experiment begins this weekend all
the staff members will be vaccinated and
in order to get inside the customers
will have to show a qr code
proving that they've either been
vaccinated or
that they have enough antibodies and
in these kind of restaurants there will
be no covet restrictions
and they will be allowed to work
during the night and i can remind you
that again only a few
days ago nightclubs bars and restaurants
were forced
to be shut down for the night we also
heard
from vladimir putin's spokesperson when
he was
asked what the kremlin thinks about the
new restrictions and
about the spike in new covert cases
dmitry paskov
said that this was due to mass
negligence by the population
uh that's how he called the refusal
of uh most citizens to
follow the restrictions also the slow
pace
of the vaccination and besides this
dimitri peskov
mentioned something that he called the
sly nature
of the virus itself so it all looks like
we're heading uh
towards a massive campaign for the whole
population
to be vaccinated new measures are being
introduced and one of the senior medical
officials here in russia said that
possibly mandatory vaccination
is something that we uh should be
waiting for
in various regions of russia only a
couple of days ago
sergey sabanyan the mayor of the russian
capital announced
that in the service sector 60
of the staff members will have to get
the first
component of the vaccine by july the
15th
you